There are several different
approaches to DFS and trees.
First, we'll talk about
pre-order traversals.
To me, the pre says,
check off a node as you see it before
you traverse any further in the tree.
There are other methods of traversal
in which you check off nodes
after you've seen their children.
So this rule is really
important to keep in mind.
We start at the route and immediately
check off that we've seen it.
Next, we pick one of the children.
Normally the left one by convention,
and check it off too.
We would continue traversing down
the left most nodes until we had a leaf.
We check off the leaf and
from there go back up to the parent.
Now we can traverse to the right
child and check it off too.
We're done with this subtree, so
we can travel back up to the root and
look at its right child.
We do the same steps until
we've seen everything.
Cool, were done!
This might seem intuitive, but
it'll make more sense once we compare it
against a different type of traversal
like an in-order traversal.
The trick here is that we're moving
through the nodes in the same order,
since this is still a DFS and
we need to explore all children first.
However, this time we're going to check
off the nodes in a different order.
We're only going to check off a node
when we've seen its left child and
come back to it.
All right,
let's see what this looks like.
Again, we start at the root, since
we haven't seen the left child yet.
We have to keep traversing
down until we hit a leaf.
We check off the leaf and
move up to the parent.
Because we've seen the left child
now we can actually check off
the parent this time.
We move on to this right node, which has
no children, so we can check it off too.
We go back up to the root and
repeat all of this on the right
side until we're done.
Why is this called in-order?
Well, we pretty much went
through the nodes in order
from the left most to the right.
We had to move up and down a lot, but if
you just look strictly at left to right,
we actually did go through
everything in order.
Lastly, we have
the post-order traversal.
This time we won't be able to
check off a node until we've seen
all of its descendants or we visited
both of its children and returned.
Similar steps, we begin at the root,
don't check it off, but
continue down to a leaf.
We check off the leaf and
move to the parent.
This time we don't check
off the parent though,
we just move on to the right node.
Once we've checked off the right child
we can go back up to the parent and
finally check it off too.
Again, we'll skip over the root node and
just move all the way down to the right.
Once everything there is good we can
move back up to the root and get it.